you know the Guardians of the Galaxy you
know their friends you know their
enemies but did you notice these cameos
in volume three
while trying to get hold of rockets
filed on the orgasphere nebula Star-Lord
and Gamora force a Record Keeper to
access it for them her name is Yura and
she is played by none other than
emerging comic book adaptation staple
Daniela melchior
you left out some important information
but
that is the gist of it melchior is
relatively new to the Hollywood scene
but she's already made quite a splash
before taking on the role of Euro she
proved to be a standout in the 2021 film
The Suicide Squad in which he played
Cleo Kazo better known as rat catcher
too additionally she voiced Gwen Stacy
in the Portuguese dub of Spider-Man into
the spider-verse before the Guardians
make it to the record room they have to
get inside the orgasphere and
fortunately for them orgo Corp doesn't
mess around when it comes to security
notably an overseer named quall watches
a various security screens that guard
the entire base koal who was last seen
in Guardians volume 3 taking a brutal
shot to the leg was played by James
Gunn's wife and frequent collaborator
Jennifer Holland coil is actually
Holland's second comic book movie role
to date as she has played Amelia
harcourse an agent of Amanda Waller in
the DC Universe She also appeared in
2019's brightburn the David yarovesky
movie that was co-produced by Gunn
the guardian's base of operations
nowhere is an odd place to say the least
situated inside the head of a dead
Celestial it was previously run by
tanalea Tavon otherwise known as a
collector the streets of nowhere have
been cleaned up since then but it's not
perfect for example nowhere is still
home to some strange and seedy
individuals by the time of Guardians
volume 3 including none other than Seth
Green's Howard the Duck Howard can be
seen playing a card game with a number
of other characters including Cosmo and
craglin green is voice a humanoid Dirk
in both the Guardians of the Galaxy
movies and the animated Disney plus
series what if
you know what they say when you're out
of luck always go duck I'm pretty sure
no one says that oh they say it really
totally
Guardians of the Galaxy volume 3's fill
in the high evolutionary is a truly
Twisted individual in his Pursuits of
building the perfect world he has
created some truly monstrous beings take
the weaponized juggernauts Behemoth and
War Pig for example a cyborg bird and
pig who obsessed with protecting the
high evolutionary and carrying out his
wishes Reynaldo fabelli provides the
voice of Behemoth and of all people Judy
Greer voiced warpic gria is no stranger
to the MCU of course as she played the
ex-wife of Scott Lang in the Ant-Man
franchise outside of the MCU Greer has
appeared in everything from Jurassic
world to the latest Halloween trilogy
and Guardians of the Galaxy vol 3 Cosmo
and craglin find themselves the Todd's
over a petty squabble he calls her a bad
dog and she refuses to stop pestering
him about taking it back which is
adamant he won't do their ongoing feud
eventually gets on the nerves of their
fellow nowhere residents one of the
individuals who's sick of hearing about
their animosity is the broker as played
by Christopher Fairbank Guardians of the
Galaxy fans will likely remember him
from the first installment in the
trilogy in which Peter Quill attempts to
sell him the arm
you got the best eyebrows in the
business
evidently the broker survived the
destruction of zandar by thanos's forces
and has since started a new life on
nowhere
Cosmo and craglands view the noise yet
another notable individual in their card
game Besame tuckaluck a desident of
nowhere who makes his big screen debut
in Guardians of the Galaxy volume 3
courtesy of Rhett Miller Miller has been
the front man and singer of the country
rock band the old 97s since the group
formed back in 1992. Miller showed off
his musical prowess in his first MCU
appearance at the beginning and the end
of the Guardians of the Galaxy holiday
special the Disney plus special sees
benzemek Tucker lock and his band The
bezumik Tucker lock and the Nowhere Men
work hard to bring some Christmas cheer
to Nowhere Unfortunately they woefully
misunderstand basically every aspect of
the holiday
set is not part of the lore at all Pete
Davidson and James Gunn have worked
together before as DC fans will likely
remember he played Black Guard in the
suicide squad for Guardians of the
Galaxy vol 3 the pair reunited again
albeit briefly and in a way that only
die-hard fans of the comedian are likely
to recognize Davidson plays a character
called flectic an alien guard of the
high evolutionary because flagtic is a
member of an undisclosed alien species
it's obviously very difficult to tell
that Davidson is there however as Gunn
noted on Twitter the actor very much put
in the work as Davidson both voice a
character and physically portrayed him
gunrose and my friend Pete's not only
voice but actually came to visit us in
Atlanta for a day and played flexic on
set
who doesn't love a good Creator came
here still you'd be forgiven for missing
James Gunn's part in Guardians of the
Galaxy Vol 3. especially considering his
character as anything but recognizable
in fact it seems like gun chose to
portray the strangest minor character in
the movie Gunn himself confirmed on
Twitter that he provided the voice of
lamb shank the unsettling yet polite
scientific experiments encountered by
mantis when she freed to high
evolutionaries prisoners at the end of
the film
eagley the eagle is a lovable CGI bird
of prey that appears prominently in
James Gunn's DC EU show Peacemaker as it
happens a very similar looking bird
turns up as one of the caged animals on
the high evolutionary ship and Guardians
of the Galaxy Vol 3. one gun took a
moment to answer some fun questions on
Twitter one viewer took the opportunity
to question whether the two birds
similarities were intentional gun
confirmed that was actually the real
eagerly in almost any other occasion the
surprise presence of a DC EU character
in an MCU movie will be Monumental news
then again sometimes a bird is just a
bird
foreign